et
[Musique]
pendant que l'insecte gégène le
propriétaire de la terre faisait sa
sieste
les shadoks et l'egypte y sont arrivés
chez lui quand l'egypte y virent que la
terre avait déjà propriétaire ils
décidèrent d'aller lui parler pour voir
comment on pourrait s'arranger mais il
ne voulez quand même pas le réveiller
pour lui parler d'affaires et ils se
retirèrent très discrète et puis sur la
fin de l'après midi
voilà les shadoks qui arrivent aussi
mais beaucoup moins discrètement
avec leur fanfare et leurs ustensiles
[Musique]
et
la sieste de gégène était fini les
ennuis commençaient la planète toutes
les questions commencent à saper la
terre l'egypte sy sall et je n'ai pas
trop il se réfugiait dans leurs fusées
blindés il regardait gégène faire du
cinéma et attendait tranquillement que
ça se calme mais les châteaux c'était
pas pareil je gèle et or dès les
grignoter les démons t il en cas c'est
comme ça un certain nombre sans compter
ce qu'il en est chez lui et qu'il
gardait pour sa consommation personnelle
si cela continue il n'y aurait bientôt
plus de château que sur la terre mais
heureusement il y avait la lune
bon
non
[Musique]